All right,
so here's the way of
thinking about things.
I'm going to move through
it relatively quickly.
So,
um,
you look through the world,
you look at the world through a frame of
reference and the reason you do that in
part is because there's more to
the world than you can understand.
And so that would be the
actual chaos of the world.
It's like the world is very,
very,
very complicated.
And you know you're a
very complicated too,
but you're not as
complicated as the world.
So you're continually surrounded by a
chaotic structure that you don't really
understand and you have to frame it
in with a frame of reference that only
allows you to see those things that are
necessary for you to see at the time of
your given action.
And as far as I can tell,
this is a cybernetic model of personality.
The elements of that frame or
something like this is a basic story.
You are somewhere,
you're located somewhere
in time and space always.
You know where that is and you have
some sense of the qualities of that
localization.
So people ask you about
that because they ask you,
well,
how are you doing?
And what they're asking is,
you know,
what's your representation of
your current state of being?
And the answer to that
is generally for people.
Um,
it's okay,
but it's insufficient because
if it wasn't insufficient,
while what,
why,
why would you be doing anything?
And then he in principle now isn't good
enough because there's something else
that could be better.
And that's what you're pursuing.
And if it's kind of a weird thing,
because it means in some sense that if
you weren't dissatisfied permanently,
you wouldn't be motivated to do anything.
And so that's also part of the reason
that a lot of human being human experience
is characterized by
somewhat negative emotions.
It's like this,
we're permanently dissatisfied.
Why?
Well,
because we can act to change things.
So if you're not dissatisfied,
you don't want it to be better.
So in some sense,
what you're doing is looking at the
world through a frame that says,
this is what there is and here's how
I evaluated and here's what could be.
And that's what I want.
I would like to bring that about.
And so that's,
uh,
that's what gives things value.
It gives things value because things that
will move you to where you want to go,
they have a positive value and things
that get in your way when you're trying to
get to where you want to go,
they have a negative value.
And so that's partly
how your emotions work.
So,
and you can put almost anything in the,
in the box of what should be.